And we're live.
What's up?
Uh,
nothing.
I was actually doing this.
Appreciate it.
Yeah.
Thanks for having me.
Oh,
look how you dressed.
Very casual look like.
Yeah.
It's all about comfort these days.
Like monk,
like he's like a lot of monk.
Like to what?
You got the shaved head and the
wooden beads and the whole deal.
Yeah.
I mean I kind of decided that like I
ever since cutting my hair that uh,
I don't know.
I'm just going to do
away with like not being,
like not being comfortable in any area.
So heels,
um,
you kinda had to pay me to do that.
Really?
Yeah.
I Dunno.
It's just the,
I'm not a big fan of heels
because I can't run away in them.
That's good point.
I think that's why they made him.
Yeah,
no,
it makes sense.
Like girls wearing tight skirts where
your legs are constricted or tight dresses
and go down to your knees especially.
Yeah.
Those things are,
that's like a thing where
girls can like barely walk.
You have the heels,
your,
your toes are down.
It's like the opposite of being strong.
It's like you're very vulnerable,
right.
Very vulnerable.
Yeah.
Like,
um,
I don't know if it's just because
of like the way I grew up,
but I was always like
looking over my shoulder.
Like anytime I was walking
down the wrong alley,
I was always,
uh,
you know,
ready to scope out the area,
just running,
be able to run.
I think everybody's like that though,
right?
I mean,
yeah.
Especially girls.
You should be.
Yeah.
I mean,
just me in particular,
just because that was the only
girl that looked like myself.
I was the smallest all the
time or youngest are like
the only white girl on my
black.
So it was always like,
uh,
I stood out and,
um,
so yeah,
I like to,
I like to be safe.
That's smart.
Yeah.
Or be able to like,
you know,
throw it kick in these pants.
Yeah.
Those were those like sweatpants
or something when he got on a,
these are called Harem pants.
Harem pants.
Yeah.
And she would get up there with that.
Oh,
they're crazy.
They're like,
they've got cool designs on them.
What are those designs?
Um,
I don't really know,
but they're very comfy and I got,
um,
they came off of this website called
Harem pants.com or something like that.
And what are the wooden beads about?
So this is,
um,
this is a guy,
I got it from a friend,
a Cassie,
rob who is also a fighter.
She's my teammate.
I'm back at home and she,
uh,
she gave it to me leading up to
the fight with Joanna and uh,
just for some strength and courage that
think this is supposed to like give you
like some type of confidence or whatever.
Yeah.
It's just like an energy beat.
I don't know if it really like,
I mean,
I guess it works,
but you know,
leave.
It works.
Exactly.
Yeah.
That's kind of how I was feeling about it.
Right.
The placebo effect.
Yeah.
I got to tell you that your victory
speech after you beat you on,
uh,
was my all time favorite because it
wasn't even just about you or about the
fight.
It wasn't about anything.
It was just you expressing yourself.
Pat,
what are you doing over there?
All right.
Try them out the cell.
Okay.
Tassel.
Yeah.
No,
uh,
I just think that,
um,
uh,
it was an awesome victory speech.
It was really amazing.
It was a,
you were,
you know,
you were just spilling your
heart out and it was in your,
your moment to shine and in
your moment to shine you,
you didn't make it about you.
I think I fight better that way,
you know,
when,
um,
you know,
it's always about me,
like throughout the training camp,
like everybody,
like my coaches and teammates,
they're always helping me and just
gets to be a bit much sometimes,
you know,
and I want to,
um,
I want to help other people.
It feels my spiritual cup more,
um,
you know,
spiritual cup.
Yeah.
I think that,
you know,
I've,
uh,
you know,
if he,
if,
if your hands close to,
to give,
you know,
you can't be open to
receive kind of thing.
And I think that,
um,
the more that I can give to people,
the more that I can get myself,
you know?
And I think that,
um,
you know,
just like plants and animals,
the way,
you know,
if you look in nature,
everything is a symbiotic relationship.
I think that humans could be the same way.
Interesting.
Where you're looking at things,
if you always looked at things like that.
No.
Uh,
uh,
I shouldn't say not always,
but a,
I always was a person that,
you know,
want it to be outside.
I want us to be in nature.
I grew up in a,
like urban jungle and Milwaukee
and just concrete everywhere,
you know,
no place to go outside except for,
just playing in the alleys and stuff.
But,
uh,
um,
my,
my lineage is from Lithuania where
they're like very in tune with nature and
they're pagans and like
slash Christian and uh,
so they really,
you know,
just,
just my whole family,
you know,
they come from living off
the land and stuff like that.
And so that's always been
something I wanted to do.
Um,
I would just put in a situation,
you know,
just to,
try and do martial arts
and trying to like,
uh,
you know,
I guess control my emotions and stuff.
Just living in this chaotic
environment that I grew up in and um,
nature is where I felt
the most piece that,
so that's always something
that I connected with.
And then the more that I kind of,
uh,
focus on nature and animals
and stuff like that,
I noticed that,
you know,
there's a,
I don't know,
I tried to live my life the same way.
Who is this interesting
leading up to that fight too?
That you are kind of like the antidote
to a lot of things that people are
getting annoyed at.
An May,
all the trash talking and
all the negativity and all
the like fighting at press
conferences,
you just shut all that shit down with you.
Ana.
There needs to be balanced.
You know,
it's like,
I mean I like entertainment,
you know,
I,
I should talk sometimes too,
you know,
but uh,
I,
there just has to be a balance,
you know?
And it has to be honest too,
like if you really feel
this way about somebody,
like if you're really
upset with this person.
Yeah.
I say how you feel,
but like don't just go out of your way
just to be entertaining because you think
it's going to be funny or something or you
think it's just going to be like,
it's not genuine,
you know?
Right.
Yeah.
But it was just the way
you handle yourself.
Like cause her whole
thing is talking shit,
the whole thing is scaring people.
I'm the Boogie woman
and coming to get you,
you know all that stuff and you were just
dead faced and I think that fucked her
head up.
Oh really?
Do you ever see that video of like the,
what was that video with all that?
Not that one.
The one you just showed me earlier,
it was like,
is this dude like standing
in front of an elephant?
And it like started charging
at him and he was like,
calm,
you know?
And he just stood there.
Yeah.
I don't know how to phrase
trample them.
Elephant is coming through and it's like,
yeah,
I've seen that just
stands there in one spot.
It stops.
Don't try that at home.
Yeah.
Obviously because you're
talking about an animal,
but it's just,
I think it's a good analogy to draw from.
Like Yolanda Energy.
She was very chaotic and very,
um,
in my face and very threatening.
Intimidating.
Yeah.
And like,
yeah,
don't go out of your way to stand in
front of an elephant is running at you.
Like,
don't put yourself in that position.
But I,
I had to be there.
That's my job.
You know?
So,
um,
so when you're in those
situations where he like,
you don't know what's,
do you know?
You just stay calm.
Yeah.
Well,
you didn't just stay calm.
You stayed eerily calm and you were like
reciting the Lord's prayer when I asked
you that,
I was like,
whoa.
It was like,
what are you saying over there?
And you're like,
I'm reciting the Lord's prayer.
Yeah.
Uh,
the whole training camp,
it was just crazy.
But like that week in particular,
like I was convinced that
this might be my last fight.
This might be my last day on earth.
Like I was so just like ready
for anything at that point.
You know,
there might be your last fight.
I don't know.
Some crazy.
I Dunno just cause,
uh,
I don't know.
I think I started to think that almost
like every fight is because it's a crazy
with stuff.
Yeah,
it's tough,
but it's the best thing in the world.
Especially the,
the,
all of the,
all of the stressors that came
along with this fight in particular,
right.
Especially all of those like [inaudible].
And then we have what we've,
we've had,
uh,
in that fight we had a,
we had a few,
like kind of,
I don't want to say magical moments,
but say for instance,
uh,
we bring Mishka with us everywhere we go.
I'm dog.
Our flight was delayed three hours,
four hours.
And when we landed,
we landed like a few hours after that
truck drove through the park and killed
all the people in New York,
which was right by our hotel,
which if we would have been there on time,
we would have feel assigned the posters
and then been outside at the park
walking Misha.
So I mean,
just little things like,
like that,
like we would have been outside maybe at
that spot and had been witness to that.
I heard it or something
and that would affected me,
you know,
and um,
the Antifa march.
Yeah.
And there is just
all this stuff about,
you know,
like people who are going to be protesting
and stuff like that and they even
like the day of the fight and I just
get a lot of anxiety over that stuff.
I get anxiety over like big
crowds of people and it's like,
you know,
just feel like crazy.
Yeah.
Um,
you know,
and it's,
uh,
yeah,
I just,
I wasn't even just thinking about the
fight when you wanna it was more than
that,
you know,
it was like,
whatever,
what all her energy represented to me.
Like all my past,
like,
um,
just negative people that,
you know,
uh,
want to want to strike
fear into your heart,
you know,
and,
um,
I wasn't gonna let that happen
even though I was scared,
but you know,
I just,
uh,
I wasn't gonna stop doing what I
was doing just because of that.
Well you were really eerily focused,
like one time she stuck her fist
in your face and touch your face.
You didn't even move.
Yeah.
Cause I know she needed
a reaction from me.
You know,
it's just like,
um,
it was just like with anybody,
you know,
so you don't give energy
to something negative,
you don't feed the fire,
you know?
Yeah.
That's gotta be a mind
fuck for her though.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
Used to people reacting to
her and headbutting going
head to head with her and
trying to show her and you just stay calm.
Yeah.
Cause I mean,
you know,
it's,
it's uh,
either you really,
I mean,
it's either one or two things.
Either you really disliked
me enough to like,
you know,
put your hands on me outside of
the competition or his fight,
you know,
or it's a character,
or are you just doing this for show?
Right.
You know,
it's either one of the two and I just
don't think she's really a bad person.
I just think that,
you know,
she's put in this position and maybe she,
that's what she felt like she had to do.
Well,
I wrote something about
the Volcker on the mirror,
uh,
Daniel Cormier fight the other day that
what owes Tamir was trying to do and
what core me was trying to do.
It's like they're trying to sow
seeds of doubt that you're trying to,
there's a real issue with someone that's
about to fight where you're about to
compete and it's this
crazy nerve wracking thing.
And the unknown is always there.
You don't know what's gonna Happen,
right?
So someone can convince you,
I'm gonna fuck you up.
You're like,
God damn is he gonna fuck me up and
really start thinking it if you,
if it's in your head.
And that one of the things that Daniel
said in that fight was that there's,
there's levels to this thing.
Like,
you think you're going to come
in and fuck me up with his car.
He's like this,
he's not you,
you're not,
you haven't experienced this yet.
Right.
And as it's something that I,
you know,
I,
uh,
have high respect for you.
You want to sue,
you know,
and I think it's great that I was putting
this position to face her because I
had to get better and are like,
I had to get up to that level,
you know,
to face her.
And I had to do a lot of research and,
uh,
work on my mental stability.
I mean,
she kept saying I was mentally
unstable like you and those,
you know,
phone calls and stuff,
like the conference calls beforehand.
And I was like,
f you were mentally unstable.
What was the cause?
Rose's mentally unstable.
Yeah.
Oh,
my dad is,
my dad was just correct.
Like in what way?
Uh,
I mean,
well,
I don't know,
to me,
I can't speak for myself,
but like,
uh,
it's just,
please do,
oh wait,
I'm sorry.
Could go it.
Okay.
It's like everyone
getting ready for a fight.
It's,
it's,
um,
there are some people who can be excited
about the fight the entire time when
they don't give a shit about
anything and they just,
they just delete it.
I love it.
And then there's also the ones who,
who get ready for a fight and
while getting ready for the fight,
it's nerve wracking.
And especially with all of
the Boogie woman and all the,
you're mentally unstable.
And then in the history with her dad and
her history growing up and just all of
those things coming to a head,
this was exactly what
rose wanted it to be,
the scariest possible situation for
her to be in New York with the end,
with the Antifa march that happened in
front of the hotel the morning of we,
we almost didn't make it to the fight.
Then march had what was going on.
This was the Anti Donald Trump march.
Yeah.
And it sounded way better than it was
walk.
Right.
We had a walk to the arena.
No,
that was year before it happened.
The morning of the fight right
through the front of the hotel,
which,
which that,
that's fine,
but rose had seen some weeks in advance,
someone somewhere posts
that Antifa was going to,
they were going to strike on November 4th.
I though they were planning,
they were planning on a strike or nothing.
Like seriously.
I was like,
we were getting ready,
like we had done our morning shake out,
you know,
uh,
and then morning shake
out the day of the fight.
We always like to,
um,
I was like to like first thing we do
when we get up is just shake it out.
Like,
cause you all your nerves and stuff.
Like all,
you're like nervous energy is inside of
you the day of the fight and you just
want to,
you don't want to go to
the arena the first time.
Breaking a sweat or getting
that heavy breathing,
you know,
because
before going to the arena,
yeah.
Light Mitt work or
uh,
actually we,
we blow it out hard.
Like when you just get it out,
you know,
like,
you know when you first started running
or something or you do a workout and you
just like breathing heavy,
like he gets your first
like heavy wind out.
That's like you just blow right through
it and then just say pads like intense,
you know,
just whatever.
I'm actually,
it is like you go off of a feel,
you know,
whenever you're feeling like some days.
Um,
when I fought Teesha I was,
uh,
like kind of sick and anti
like on antibiotics cause
I like got the red tide or
something say like,
and I barely slept and like,
so I didn't,
our shakeout was not very long.
Like it was like,
okay,
I gotta save my energy
to get to the arena.
So we barely even did want,
but like for this one,
um,
shakeout was pretty normal.
You know,
it,
we just hit pads,
your parents for about seven minutes
and then she shadowbox real hard.
Yeah,
five minutes.
And then
maybe it might do a little bit of
grappling or something like that,
but yeah.
And then I'll go take a nap.
Like,
you know,
uh,
can a shower,
you know,
kind of visualized and just like lay down,
not even take a nap,
but just like close your eyes.
And it was like the same
thing on the day of a fight.
I barely even eat on a fight day.
Like I,
the way I cut weight as,
I'll do like a,
the day before I'll do it.
I mean,
I don't really have to
cut that much weight,
so,
um,
but like I'll do like a juice fast,
like,
oh,
for one day I'll just drink fluids.
Um,
and then the next day I'll sit in a
hot shower and then just sweat it out.
Um,
because I don't like to,
I,
I don't like to,
um,
dehydrate myself too much.
Like I'd rather have
fluids and no food then,
then lots of food in my stomach,
no fluids.
Right.
And she's talking about
sweating out two pounds.
I set up no like five pounds
last time you have a bigger,
no.
Uh,
this fight was,
I think it was like one 25 30.
I can't remember.
I think like the week of the fight I was
like one 27 and like by the time wait
cause started,
I was like one 25 ish.
You're cutting timber one 20.
She was what?
She was fine.
Now one thing I can't remember,
I don't even know.
Oh,
when we started the way gushy
rose walks around lately.
Lately because of uh,
this is just the growth and size lately
she's been walking around one 25,
one 27 but uh,
every,
every fight it'll like
the day before William.
She's,
yeah,
but I'm talking about going to the sauna.
Are we going to do to get this one off?
It's like I man,
you'll spit.
So you,
um,
you don't have like a particular type
of food that you like to eat the day of
a kind of food like carbohydrate
rich or like what do you want?
Depends on where I'm at.
So like,
you know,
because every place has different food
and like some places they just like nasty
food.
But I'm in New York,
there's this like little smoothie shop
across the street and there's this like
most delicious smoothie that I like,
just had it always,
what a chocolatier.
Oh this is really good.
So I had that like every day of the week.
And that was,
I think the day of the fight.
I had like a little bit of that,
but I don't know.
Um,
when he used the,
when Marty Morgan was his coach,
he's always used to say like,
you know,
you have enough food and energy in you
to sustain you for the five days more
just like mentally,
like if you want to eat something.
Right.
But,
um,
so I so ever since he had ever said that,
I was like,
yeah,
I never,
I never wanted to eat during
fight day cause I'm just like,
so yeah,
you can't,
you can't digest it.
You have to be like relaxed and
kind of dire to follow normally.
Ah,
I try and make everything
homemade as possible.
So that's like kind of my thing,
you know,
I'm never like,
I'm never anti anything
I don't like to be like,
I mean except for lots of sugar and
obviously like things that are like
obviously bad for you.
Um,
I like to,
yeah,
I like to make everything from
scratch as much as possible.
And the more,
yeah.
Um,
the more like the more,
uh,
process as something takes in
order to make it from scratch,
I think the less you should eat it.
You know,
like if like something like bread,
you know,
if you do it from scratch,
like make your own a starter
culture and like you,
um,
that takes like a week by
itself and you have to add more,
add flour and water to it,
like over time as he's another two weeks.
So like,
you shouldn't be eating bread every day,
you know,
so it takes a lot of work.
But like,
say,
you know,
if you have like a garden,
you've got tomatoes,
which,
you know,
we grew the last camp,
uh,
you know,
you could just eat those real easy
cause you just pick it and eat it.
So you make your own bread too?
Um,
I,
I tried once and it was,
it was all right,
but sorry,
go on it a little bit more,
but that's like my goal,
you know,
it's like to try and make
everything from scratch.
And that's interesting.
She's at your Gerald Kabuga.
Oh yeah.
By the way,
this is pretty good.
Like normally I don't,
oh,
like,
uh,
I would um,
use this brand to like make my own gts.
Yeah.
Like to do like the
starter scoby and whatever.
But um,
I usually don't like them just like bye.
But this one was pretty good.
Yeah.
GTS,
my favorite there.
Then you'd have to have a
driver's license to purchase that.
You have to be over 21.
Really?
Yeah,
because it's got more than one
half of 1% alcohol by volume,
so it's impossible to get drunk off of it.
I mean,
yeah,
just got a very marginal,
because of the fermentation,
there's a marginal amount
of natural alcohol in it.
Yeah.
So you have,
but that's the good ones.
The other other ones you
can buy in any store,
those aren't.
Yeah.
It was just like,
yeah,
they don't even have
like the Scoby and I'm,
I like,
I like making it myself though,
cause I think it tastes a lot better.
Like I'll use green
teams that a black teen,
um,
all I add ginger and
stuff like that to it.
Okay,
cool.
Yeah,
I did that for a while.
I just get tired of it.
Yeah.
Big Bowls.
Land around the experiments.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But it's fun.
It's fun to do.
But I was doing that in the 90s.
Yeah.
Way,
way back.
Yeah.
I got one from Andy Dick and Dick gave
me like he was making in his house.
He gave me some,
I was like,
this is actually pretty good.
Yeah,
yeah,
I know.
So,
so yeah,
like diet wise,
I mean I try not to be
too scientifical on stuff,
but um,
you know,
uh,
whatever,
like whatever feel good,
like whatever makes you feel good,
I think is what you should eat.
Um,
and you don't,
I don't like sweets or anything like that.
I don't really,
I grew up,
you know,
my mom was Lithuanian,
like,
uh,
my parents were actually late
Lithuanian refugees that came.
I'm first generation American and we grew
up eating sauerkraut and potatoes and
you know,
just real eastern European types of,
so I never really,
I never really like candy
or anything like that.
So I've always just been,
it's been like a lifestyle
for me and never like,
uh,
a thing that I'm on this
diet that I have to do.
And you know what I mean?
Right.
Now.
How did you get involved in martial arts?
Um,
I said they had put a,
uh,
put my,
me and my brother am taekwondo,
like from a young age.
And then from there,
you know,
it was just such a positive thing for me,
just cause like it kept us out of trouble,
Eh,
you know,
taught me how to defend myself,
gave me confidence,
things like that.
Um,
and then we also like watch lot
of dragon ball z growing out.
So like we,
you know,
we were like,
that as is or whatever and
without get power up his stuff.
So it was a fun thing for like as kids.
And then we kind of,
it kind of just evolved into more
of like a real life application and,
um,
you know,
babies and make fun of us,
like,
you know,
for doing that.
But we all also use,
again,
like little fights on like in
our neighborhoods and stuff.
And um,
you know,
my love for martial arts grew from that.
And then I just wanted
to try every martial art,
you know,
it's like,
the like,
like a flavors of ice cream,
you know,
you just wanted to try all of it.
So,
so I tried,
um,
uh,
karate after that.
Then,
uh,
that's where I got introduced
to Jujitsu for the first time.
Like real basic,
you know,
positional things and then,
um,
you know,
weapons and stuff.
Uh,
yeah,
I did stick fighting for a while.
That was pretty fun.
Yeah.
Uh,
with like you get like
the head cage on you,
it's like whack each other.
But um,
and then a pankration.
And then after that,
once I got into high school,
I was doing a lot of sports and
stuff like cross country basketball,
track,
everything.
Like I just try to be
as active as possible.
Try and stay busy.
Cause yeah,
I did a little,
like one season,
the wrestling as a senior and then,
uh,
you know,
I,
I came to,
I did kickboxing and I met pat at
Duke groups as Jim and Milwaukee.
And then that's kind of where
I saw guys like him at the pet,
all those dudes like
doing as a profession.
So I was like,
I mean I could do that
as a profession too,
you know?
Wow.
And how old were you at the time?
So I first walked into Duke Jamal's
I think I was like 14 and then I left
because I had like other
obligations and like,
you know,
stopped training for a while,
but I was still doing other sports
and stuff and they came back,
you know,
when I was like 17.
So you were really thinking at that time
like maybe this would be something you
could do for a career.
Um,
you know,
not for sure,
but like definitely like I
saw I was always going to
be involved in martial arts
no matter what.
So like as a hobby,
did you have another thing that you were
thinking of doing before that though?
Like when you were
thinking about your future?
Yeah.
I mean,
I knew that I had to
do something for money.
So like I tried a semester of
college and realized it's like,
this isn't just like high school,
but I'm paying for it.
Like this is stupid.
So I stopped going.
Um,
I really liked,
um,
English and so I thought maybe I
could go and sad or like I said,
I try and push me into
computers and I was like,
this is stupid.
Like,
I'm good at.
I just really doesn't excite me at all.
And so you're like,
that sounds a little,
if she wasn't,
uh,
doing more shorts right now,
she'd be,
should I not be touching this?
I don't know.
I was just like,
just weird over there
making a lot of emotion.
I'm hanging this up,
man.
I think rose would have been farming.
Yeah.
So like my,
um,
yeah,
that's always been like,
my thing is like,
uh,
you know,
and they asked us what we want to be
when I grow up is I always said I want to
be a farmer.
Like ever since I was a kindergartner.
Just because you liked the idea of
growing things out of the ground.
And like you were saying before,
making your own food from scratch and
yeah.
A tomato from your garden that you grew
tastes so much better than from the
store.
Now when you two started hanging out
and pat had already been accomplished
kickboxer who was an MMA fighter and did
that sort of embolden you to the idea?
Uh,
oh,
so the fighting like professionally.
Yeah.
And then I,
that's when I saw,
uh,
you know,
Gina Carano end and a
Cyborg finding at the same,
uh,
like that big fight that they had.
And then that's kind of
what inspired me to like,
I was like,
oh,
I can take this to the next level.
Wow.
The Gina Carano thing that got
a lot of people in the MMA,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
She was the first,
a lot of people don't even know
a lot of these kids today that,
you know,
know about Ronda Rousey and they
got to introduce into the sport.
Gina Carano was the original Ronda Rousey.
She was the one back in the day.
Yeah.
I liked her a lot.
Um,
you know,
she definitely,
she broke some barriers,
you know,
and then I would say Rhonda came after
her and took it to like even quadruple
that.
So,
um,
it's,
it's awesome.
What does it feel like
to be the champ now?
Because that's a crazy,
that's a crazy thing.
It's a crazy thing that happened.
Fight was insane.
And if people thought
you were going to win,
they probably thought you'd win by
submission or maybe by decision,
but when you cracked her in the first
round and dropped her and put her away and
then DC starts screaming,
thug,
thug grows.
Yeah.
That was like one of my favorite
times commentating with DC too,
because yeah,
he just was overcome with emotion.
Just couldn't help it.
Yeah.
Um,
I don't know,
man.
It's like somebody asked me like,
what's different since you've been champ?
And I'm like,
really?
I'm just sitting here trying to
figure out what is different.
You know,
like obviously you're
sitting here talking to you,
like,
that's cool,
but I'm talking to you before.
Yeah.
I mean talk to you now that
this crazy thing happened.
Right,
right.
Um,
so yeah,
I mean things are different,
you know,
like,
I definitely notice more,
more people,
uh,
recognizing me.
Do you have a very unique
look to with your shaved head?
Yeah.
I can't hide or you don't have to
wear a ways to go to the movies.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
And you guys are going
to fight again in April.
Back in New York.
Yeah.
That'd be cool though.
Growth come to Brooklyn,
coming to Brooklyn.
And what,
when you,
when the fight was over,
what did you,
what did you take some time off?
Like how did you did it?
Did it even sink in?
Oh yeah.
We had to go,
we had to get the fuck out of there.
We had to go home.
Like,
um,
like all of that stuff.
Like the,
you know,
the,
the truck accident and like
the protests and all this,
you know,
paranoid that I had,
I had to,
um,
hideaway,
I'm,
I'm a hermit,
so like I like to like to be,
we went straight to the airport,
two 30,
two 30 in the morning or
flight wasn't until at 9:00 AM
there was gonna be a marathon,
right?
Yeah.
The next day.
Yeah,
we heard there's going to be a marathon,
but also rose did what she did
and as soon as it happened,
we all went,
oh fuck.
Oh right.
Like I robbed a bank.
Like,
oh,
like
everybody be cool.
Just keep smiling.
Wow.
Yeah.
That was it.
He's
like,
I knew that was going to happen.
Like I actually,
um,
I actually envisioned me knocking her
out with like a Burka and the third round
because I thought she's going to be like
overly aggressive after a certain point
as she would get frustrated.
That didn't happen cause it,
you know,
uh,
she thought I was throwing a jab,
but yeah.
Why do you think that?
I mean when you went into that fight,
she was such an overwhelming favorite.
She was thought of as being one of the
pound for pound top fighters in any way
class.
And why did you think that
you're going to knock her out?
Because everybody tries to take her down.
Everybody is so desperate for the
take down that it's like her striking,
I mean this from what I see is,
I mean I sit across from volunteering
shut Chenko and like we go like back and
forth.
Like it's not a thing to me.
Like I got Pat Barry,
pat A's,
you're burying my corner.
I got Trevor Whitman and my
corner and I've done taekwondo.
A striking like my whole life.
Like it's not something
that I've never seen before.
Right.
You know,
and just that Dutch style,
like kickboxing,
like it's great.
It's hard,
it's very intimidating
to send across from,
but you can,
you know,
it's very rhythmic on the beat.
Like it's not,
I don't know,
it's,
it's just something that,
it looks scary,
but it's not to be scared of,
you know?
That's interesting to where you're putting
it because most people thought of her
as being like this very solid.
Her fundamentals are rock solid.
She's incredibly technical.
Yeah.
Vicious Jab.
No,
but you just saw that the
rhythm was predictable.
I mean,
we knew everything she was
going to do before she did it,
watching it for a long time.
Right.
You know,
like,
and she is the,
the like,
I mean she has the most dominant female.
Like these girls could not hang with her,
you know,
and she's still the best out there,
isn't been on the radar
since she'd be Carla.
Like we knew that that was the
fight as soon as she'd be calling.
And it was just a matter of
how were we going to get there.
Like what route are we
going to take to get there?
And so when the fight came around a big,
a big,
this whole,
this entire training camp was mental.
It wasn't physical.
The whole training camp every
day was mental mentality,
mind,
mental,
mental strength,
just mental,
mental,
mental.
The entire training camp.
And one of the keys to the fight was
knowing what she's going to do before she
does it.
And I mean,
not just in the fight,
but in the interviews,
in the press conference,
backstage,
like we,
we,
we knew everything that was going to
happen and it all happened exactly the way
we knew it was coming to.
Wow.
Yeah.
This was,
this was an excellent dissection
of a person of an athlete.
Now what is the feeling like
having gone through that,
having accomplished it,
having literally blown
it out of the water,
right?
Yeah.
Did you smashed in the first round?
Crazy moment?
Yeah.
Now you gotta do it again.
I know.
Yeah.
That was the tough part.
What's,
what's the,
what's the thought process?
Um,
you know,
just,
uh,
you can't make the,
what was the saying?
He always like,
I don't get messed up,
but she can't paint the model.
It's twice,
you know,
like,
right.
So it can't be the same approach.
You know,
it has to be something different.
It has to be.
Um,
but you know,
at the same time,
and if it ain't broke,
don't fix it either.
So like,
uh,
it's gotta be a combination of like,
yeah,
we're to keep doing what we're doing,
but,
you know,
keep getting better
obviously all the time.
I mean,
I sounds a little general cliche.
We don't prepare for one
in particular person.
It's always were roses on the
road to getting her black belt.
And that's what the,
that's what the mission is.
I mean,
of course we do get into
particulars based on who it is,
but that's only for a
very short period of time.
The whole goal is just to make Rose A.
Black belt in every,
in grappling,
wrestling,
striking.
Yeah.
Everything.
Just,
just become a black belt,
become a master of all of it.
And that's been
even another,
like he was saying the mentality
of this last training camp,
it wasn't just like a,
you know,
okay,
I'm going to,
I mean,
a journal,
which I do during all that are all like,
you know,
like we talked about just doing like
a float tank or something like that.
Like those little mental exercise.
They're great,
but also like,
um,
uh,
working on creativity with it.
I was just doing the number
of ice baths she took.
Oh yeah.
I did lot ice mass.
I said,
yeah.
Oh the last one was the worst.
Like I said,
the last,
every day,
every day to a point where it actually
became challenging for me to get the
water colder.
Cause I was like,
this is ridiculous how she
didn't get in and within,
under now it's gotten to a point
now it had been under 25 seconds.
Like the,
you know,
when you first get it,
like boom,
right.
Like he's under 20 seconds on 20
seconds and she's just stone faced.
It's just amazing.
Yeah.
The last one that I did,
like it was hurting so bad.
I was like crying.
Like I never had either where I
started crying because it hurts a bit.
But anyway,
like,
yeah,
so that,
and then onto a lot of benefit from that.
Yeah.
I do like,
I mean the,
yeah,
reduction of inflammation.
Yeah.
And there's just like mentally,
mentally and emotionally to,
um,
you know,
cause it's like,
why is it so scary?
But it hurts,
you know?
Um,
but it's,
it's good.
I mean,
if you can get in the cold ice baths
and nobody's sitting across from you is
gonna scare you.
It was less scary than the cold.
But,
uh,
also,
and I wasn't,
I was trying to say this the whole time,
but,
uh,
I've been also getting back into piano
because I used to play piano as a kid and
I got away from that ever since.
Like moving from state to state and not
having an actual panel just to keyboard.
It's like stupid trying
to play on a keyboard,
but I finally got a piano in my house.
And so like that's another thing that I
started incorporating into my training,
just like training my mind and
just be more creative and um,
just having like outlet too.
That's interesting.
So you feel like that benefits you just,
just being creative on a piano and,
yeah,
I think there's a lot of parallels
between music and fighting.
Oh yeah,
I think so too,
pat.
I don't know.
I don't,
well yeah,
he's,
I was,
I was classically trained
in piano and jazz,
um,
in high school and I was,
uh,
my mom's a pianist and so like it kind
of runs in the family and so we have been
doing that as long as I've been doing
martial arts and it's just a good balance,
you know,
just like gardening or
anything like that is to,
you know,
fighting and hurting people.
Well it's weird.
I think it,
it,
it almost made like almost help with her
body mechanics in a way to be able to
control an individual finger at different
times in hitting one beat on left hand
in a different,
totally different,
something on the right hand and,
and to be able to just do that,
but over and over and over and over again,
no matter how many times
you play the same song,
you just keep playing it and you love
playing it like over and over again.
I think that that,
that,
that put,
that gives rose like a
cat like balance in a way.
That's interesting.
If you've seen,
no,
I'm sure you have seen a lot of those
things that people are doing now.
We're a light will go up on a board.
You have to touch the live like Llama
Chanko does a lot of that stuff.
Or there's,
there's these things that are supposed
to like be training your neurocognitive
function,
right.
And your ability to
react quickly to things.
Right.
But there's probably
some parallels in that,
right?
I would think so.
I mean like,
like we said before,
it's like if you believe in and it works,
you know?
Yeah.
Whatever makes you feel good.
Like maybe makes you happy too.
And there is a huge
idea for the second one who we've,
we've been seeing the,
the lights and the touch,
this and that.
Um,
and I think for this next fight coming up,
uh,
a big,
um,
roses next evolution in her,
in her game I think is going
to be kind of like a sniper,
like accuracy.
So we have an idea of having rose
punching tennis balls out of the air.
Have you ever tried that hat?
You know that happened?
The tennis balls on the hat?
Yeah.
I haven't tried that yet.
Huh?
Yeah.
Don't like that.
You don't like that hat?
Why?
I think,
I don't know.
I mean,
what's it for accuracy?
Lama Chanko loves it.
He does a lot of,
it was a pretty cool dude.
Yeah.
I know he's a man at it,
but I,
in my own opinion,
I think this is staring at this
thing and where's it going?
Like a double MBA is awesome fluid.
It's just got that tennis
ball in front of him.
He's being fluid.
Yeah.
Can you see him practicing with it?
That's cool.
As your mug man.
Accuracy.
Like I said,
that's,
that's somewhat of an idea that we'd like.
We have an idea for this next year,
any camp where we're going
to be launching tennis balls.
I rose and having her punch
balls out of midair but not,
but not,
not hitting the ball.
Right.
Standing there and throwing jabs as the
ball drops right in front of a booth.
No punching the ball and light throwing
but throwing real punches versus your
own idea that you came up with.
Yeah,
I had a dream.
It was weird,
man.
It was,
I just saw it in and if we throw multiple
balls at you in different ways and she
can like throw a real jab in,
hit a ball,
boom,
then then she'll be able to,
I think her reflections for
hitting someone right in the tooth,
you know,
while they're moving right.
He's going to be a ad is more elevated
and this is like just,
you know,
this is like I said,
we're,
we always add new stuff,
you know,
it's like,
it's never,
um,
we don't ever go away from
hitting a freaking bag,
you know,
or do I at work,
like you got to do things that roadwork.
Yeah.
I love running.
I,
you know,
I did cross country and track in
high and I was really good at it,
but I think,
um,
I was trying to run for the wrong reasons.
Like I was trying to just
get a scholarship and get
out of the house and just go
away,
you know,
like,
so I was like,
I felt like it was more of a job then.
It was like just for fun and now
I run for fun and it's great.
You know,
it's just like a,
um,
I dunno.
I think there's a book called
born to run and it's great.
I think,
I think we're all born
around the middle shoes.
Yeah.
I have some tennis or toe shoes.
And like my brother,
like he takes it to an
a whole nother level.
He like does barefoot to be completely,
yeah.
I'm like,
he's crazy,
but I try it a little bit,
but um,
yeah.
But supposedly,
uh,
this is anything,
I am my brother,
my brother.
It's a little different and he's
a whole nother level to be though.
Wow.
Yeah.
No.
Who organizes your training camp?
Does Trevor do it or do you
guys all do it together?
We're all,
uh,
we're all like a team.
That's the key to our little circle
is like always having team meetings.
Everybody being on the same page.
We're not going from one
gym to the other to like,
you know,
where this coach don't know really what
I'm doing or what I just did with this
other coach.
Like,
we're all really good friends
and we all grow together.
Four of us,
Trevor,
Tony Rose,
me.
Yeah.
No,
we have teammates.
But the core circle is just for people,
the people that are in charge of how the
like fight handling as what we like to
call it.
Because it's like,
I mean,
you don't see flamey whether
they're going to a boxing class,
you know,
his voluntariness shift,
tranquil been Denver now she's not.
She went back to Texas,
but she,
what was it last year in January?
Was it last year?
Almost all of 2017 is
a phenomenal training.
Part of
that was perfect timing.
That was one of the best
things that she's so technical.
Yeah.
She's so good.
That check right hook that she
throws is when she fought Holly,
shot Holly down with a checkbook
and she's got really good Jujitsu.
It's,
yeah,
just grind and
you submit a Julianna Pena.
I was like,
Oh shit.
Underrated.
Everybody's scared of her.
Striking her physical strength
too is also very impressive too.
Or she muscles,
people built off angry lady,
you know,
I like,
uh,
she's,
she's tough and I'm a big fan.
So,
um,
you know,
when I heard that you
were training with her,
I was like,
Ooh,
that is,
you want to sharpen the sword.
Yeah.
Iron sharpens iron.
And I think too,
I think like a lot of girls aren't
used to training with other girls.
You know,
where to train with other guys.
So it's like,
I think it's essential for us
to get together every once a,
doesn't have to be all the time,
you know?
Cause when a girl gets like,
if I get you like another girl with
something or she gets me with them,
I get so much more angry at
it then like say if like,
you know,
somebody like powers another dude,
like gets me with some,
you know.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
So when you're doing your camp,
say how many weeks out you say,
or I can't begins now,
like say you have this April 7th fight.
Yeah.
How many weeks out will you,
uh,
will you just say it's time to go to war?
I like,
I like to close everything off like five
weeks out or like four or five weeks
out.
Like that's like where we hit it hard and
depends on the scenario and
who it is and where we are.
Like everything is a day by
day feel like there's no,
you eat this on fight week and this is
the shake out that we're going to do.
It's gonna be five rounds.
It's all based on the circumstances.
Like still the last training camp because
we did like three training camps with
volunteers had Shangle
back to back for her.
Like do things that really
aren't like what I've,
you know rose was a great training.
Boarding.
Yeah.
Like,
like I,
this is not the way
that I would try and uh,
phase her,
you know?
But yeah,
certain opponents.
Yeah.
So like just going through all
of that and all those challenges,
I'm going into this last fight,
we kinda just pulled it back.
Like it was very not
intense at all actually.
It was a lot more
focused on like you said,
the mental part and like doing a lot of,
you know,
visualization and like self
awareness kind of exercises.
Valentine is going to 25 now.
Right?
Okay.
Yeah.
They should be fighting
in February 3rd so yeah.
And she's been,
she's been in Texas I
think training down there.
So yeah.
And this it,
like I said it all,
all on feeling we should deal
with Valentino was off camp.
So that was three training
camps back to back to back.
She had a fight than Valentini came
back and he was just more nonstop in the
way,
the way that Valentina is capable of
doing what she's doing because she trains
like,
I mean everybody who's
good trains like an animal,
everybody does 10 oh one yeah.
Yeah.
You have to tell him 10:00 AM to 1:00 PM
and Pablo sits there and like the roses
necessarily emulating someone.
Powell rose,
go get her go attack attack and if and if,
and if she's not acting right,
go get pat,
he'll get her like attack.
Like it's just nice.
I bet girl is tough man.
She was one of the biggest blessings
for this training camp to come around.
Yeah.
So,
so five weeks out is when
you really get crazy.
Now having already face you ana and having
defeated her so soundly in the first
fight is,
I don't want to ever say that there's a
possibility you could underestimate her
because obviously she's a very
dangerous and threatening woman,
but how do you keep it fresh?
Like how do you,
how do you approach this with the same
sort of intensity and anxiety that you
had in the first fight
that ramped up like your,
your performance?
I mean that was a big part of how turned
on you were and how tuned in you were.
Yeah.
Um,
I've had,
uh,
I almost get like more pressure
anxiety off of like rematches.
I mean I have all my other
past experiences to draw from.
So you know,
like when I rematched Teesha there was a
lot of lessons learned there and I have
to kind of apply those same lessons to
going forward or like other opponents
where it could be,
there's many like a list of reasons
to underestimate this person.
Like,
I have to remember that,
um,
anything can happen at
any moment in any way.
It can be dangerous.
And then at the end of the day,
you know,
whatever's meant to be is meant to be,
like I remember one time in the
middle of the training camp,
I had like,
you know,
I liked my little Yogi teas
where they like say like little,
you know,
saying on it and it was something like,
if it belongs to you,
it'll come to you or something like that.
And so it was just like,
Kinda,
that's how I feel about the belt.
It's like,
you know,
don't go chasing the belt,
just Isabelle's meant to be yours.
It's meant to be yours and do everything
that you can to keep it and do
everything that you can to just
be the best version of you.
But,
you know,
don't put that pressure on yourself that
I have to be the champion or I have to
do this,
you know,
cause y'all have to do anything.
The whole quest has been to see if
like it's just the mentality has been,
let's see if I'm better
than this next person,
someone out there is better than me.
Someone eventually is going,
maybe you want me someone out,
there's better.
We just need to find out who it is
and it might be the next person.
Even if it's someone who we
previously thought it might be her.
So we have to be as the the most ready
possible because we don't know who that
individual is.
And I think also like focusing on keeping
the mentality of like being curious
rather than having a need to
know that you're the best.
Like just being curious
if you're the best.
I think that's a healthy way to approach
it rather than needing to know like,
I am better than you.
It's like,
I don't know,
cause we're all the same.
We're all human beings,
you know,
like at the end of the day,
like if it's meant to be,
it's meant to be.
But you went into that fight
wholly confident that you
were better at than her.
Yeah.
You're right.
Uh,
no.
I mean,
I definitely feel like I'm
the better martial artists,
you know,
better and the better fighter too.
And it's just,
um,
there,
yeah.
I have a lot of going for me,
but I just have to
remember these things that,
you know the truth.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Stay focused,
keep stay hungry.
Yeah.
Now when it comes to
strength and conditioning,
how do you,
how do you parse that out?
Like how do you,
uh,
what,
how much time do you spend doing that
versus how much do you spend on skill
work?
It's almost like almost all scale work.
I mean,
I shouldn't say all,
but it's like the strength
and conditioning isn't
something that we like is,
is on the first,
on the priority list.
It's kind of just like if we want to
change it up or do something different,
like I started doing,
um,
uh,
sorry,
we just got our bikes and
that's been fun to do.
But it's,
I feel like strength and
conditioning should kind of just be,
I don't know.
I,
I'm not,
I don't really believe in all these like,
like strain the conditioning coach.
I think whatever you believe in is
what you know works for you and that it
works.
Right.
Um,
but for me,
that's something that I don't really,
I feel like a hamster in a wheel.
If I'm going into like some guy
telling me to do these exercises and,
and do this station and then go
to this thing for amount of time.
Like I just,
I want to be free.
Like,
ah,
I want to be,
you know,
running outside,
I want to do something
that makes me happy.
And like,
or for example,
like when we went to Indonesia and we,
uh,
we built or ships for like an entire
month and like we did manual labor.
Like what is that worth ship?
It's a,
it's a self sustaining houses.
I never of the people know what the fuck.
I think John knows everything
and knows everything.
I've never known you
to not know something.
I'm a curious person.
That's a shift.
Our is a self sustaining house that,
um,
is built off of lake
recycle materials and uh,
there's a,
there's a documentary on it called a
garbage warriors and this dude Michael
Reynolds,
he's in New Mexico and he,
he fought against
legislation like in there,
in a community to make a
earthship community and um,
New Mexico.
Yeah.
And so he fought,
I don't,
I can't remember how long it was,
but like,
like 40 years or something
crazy like went to court.
Like we need to have
this because you know,
and they just want to let them,
you know,
so they eventually got it.
I think I built the entire
community and it's cool.
You can go there and like
check it out in Taos,
New Mexico.
It's,
it's awesome.
And you can like rent some and
check it out off grid living.
It looks like star wars,
like it's ridic
because it was built into the ground.
Jamie,
Jamie is going to pull something up.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Fucking hell cool.
Yup.
The coolest.
Maybe you can have like
occupied in New Mexico.
I need to check out New Mexico.
Goddammit.
Let there's know when you're going.
There's a hot spring that we go through.
Wow.
It's cold towels.
You know what?
We got to go there and
interview Rick Strassman.
That's where he lives.
He lives in [inaudible].
He says all hippies.
That place is dope picture of that house.
That house looks fucking bad ass shit.
The thing is they're not just,
there's not just built anywhere.
Like they,
they,
they do some type of coordinated so the
house faces a certain like key direction
and the sun comes through and keeps the
like uh,
monitors a 70 degrees is like,
like the best possible way.
Yeah.
They're closing up the interior.
Yup.
It's cool.
And it's like you're going
to have aquaponics inside
and they like have banana
trees growing in the middle of New Mexico,
you know,
and you can like fish in your living room.
Like
we'll do shit like that.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
Fish in your living room.
I mean you can have like
your like aquaponics,
you know where your fish
are and you got your plants
and the fish shit fertilizes plants.
I've seen a lot of that.
Yeah.
Wow.
Look at this crazy
look at that.
And they're built,
they're built into the ground.
So like a,
they're,
they're really resistant to,
they're really dope.
You want to move?
Yeah.
So we went to Indonesia
and built one of these,
uh,
for like 30 days and we did a,
like a whole,
uh,
youtube,
like little video on it and stuff.
And just crazy.
Uh,
my,
my uh,
Doug Diaries,
I have like a youtube channel.
I haven't done a thug diaries.
[inaudible] gross.
How'd you that name?
Um,
how,
how can you get this thug?
Because I had to,
well,
so you know my ice cold stare
and he's Sarah Nono on it.
That's,
I've developed that long ago,
you know,
cause I was never a weighty person.
I never had like a good
comeback for anything,
so I just had to beat people
that I was like those big,
all right.
The like scare off like the l series.
So that's kind of where it came from.
And,
uh,
my neighbor,
I had some Jamaican neighbors that,
uh,
her name is Erica Gibbs and,
um,
she always used to be like,
that's the cross right there as you know,
it's still everybody like test the girls.
We see.
She crazy.
Yeah,
it does.
Telling you that is one of my fondest
memories when DC was screaming that out.
Hey,
yes,
genuine moment man.
Oh,
it was 100% of people gave
him a hard time about that.
I was like,
dude,
don't ever change that.
That is one of the things
that makes you amazing.
The fact that he's common doing
commentary and it's like we're on a couch
together watching the fight at home.
Whoa.
Genuine happiness.
Yeah.
It was like he was enjoying that moment
and it's animated and it was just,
it was so stunning and shocking and
that was his real honest reaction.
Right.
That was cool.
I liked DC,
but yeah,
so that's,
that's why I feel like it
strained the conditioning.
I think that was the best,
uh,
like as shoveling stuff,
like picking up heavy buckets
and tires and things like that.
Like it,
it made me feel like I was actually
doing something rather than just like a
hamster on a wheel.
Just like,
okay,
I'm working out and I'm
getting in better shape,
but I feel like I could be actually doing
something productive here and getting
muscles too.
Right.
So to answer the question and we don't
really do the strength and condition that
we do isn't like a wouldn't
know was not weightlifting and
I mean sometimes you know
that if we feel like it,
but you know,
how do you know when to do it?
Like say if you're in a camp,
like you say like when do you know when
you want to lift weights or something?
I mean it like for this last
training camp I barely lifted away.
I don't think I,
we hardly ever do like [inaudible] is
more like off season kind of thing.
Like,
if we're just like,
oh,
let's just go to 24 for fun,
walk around all day with a 40 pound
weight vest on one's shadow boxing,
shadow vice is the best
workout you could possibly do.
Because like,
I think people don't like people
practice hitting pads all the time.
Um,
but if you don't ever
practice missing a punch,
you will get tired.
Like if you throw three punches and
miss right and you never practice it,
you'll be surprised at how tired you are.
Yeah.
Is kind of incredible how tired you get
missing things and it doesn't make sense
to people.
And if you ask people
shadowbox even professionals,
they suck.
It's like,
well,
you know,
they just don't do it with no emotion.
No.
Like visualizing like
something in front of you.
Like,
um,
if you ever watched like,
uh,
my old g Jitsu coach back in Minnesota,
Greg Nelson favorite,
watch him shadow box.
He's like,
he's like fighting people and kill it.
People like,
yeah,
he's got
a great video on shadowboxing is Joseph
Valtellina my glory champion and he's
got a whole series of things
put up on his youtube.
He's got some great
instructional youtube videos,
but one of the things that he'd went and
talked about is that you should think
of that as like,
you're fighting,
you should visualize like fighting and
you're going through scenarios in your
head.
You know,
you're checking kicks and
countering with right hands and,
and delivering techniques.
That's where a lot of people,
they,
I think they,
they forget about the,
the imagination part of shadowboxing way.
People would like,
they'd leave that out,
they think,
okay,
stand there,
throw some punches,
throw some kicks,
stretch my tricep twice and then go
to more punches and move my head once.
And that's it.
They're not actually visualizing someone
in front of you throwing punches and
kicks out you and fighting
back and they're not
visualizing someone reacting to
the punches that you're throwing.
Yeah.
And firing back and moving around.
And uh,
when it comes to shadow boxing up,
that's,
that's what we really are the
conditioning by 40 pound weight vest on,
walk around all day just so you don't
even do anything will just stay home all
day with a weight vest on.
One.
Do you do that?
Okay.
Yeah.
Good dog park bike,
bike ride.
Wait versus Nice.
And um,
what do you,
what is good about the weight vest?
What was it was that thing that they
used to get into Dragon Ball Z hyperbolic
time chamber?
No.
What was the gravity,
the gravity thing that they got it.
Yeah.
Oh well that's just part of like,
this is just like such a reoccurring
theme in the Dragon Ball z series is like
just gravity training and like,
cause once you take your weight vest off,
you just feel lighter,
can breathe a lot easier if you can get
a costume breathing with a weight vest,
just sitting on your shoulders all day
and moving around with this thing and
this just
in Bra.
And then when you take it
off and we take it off,
it's almost like as if
you instantly helium
do you like you carry like backpacks
and stuff when you go hunting and stuff?
Yeah.
The pack that I wear that has a,
a bolt on it for a Olympic plates.
It's called a,
an atlas weight trainer by a
company called a outdoorsman.
And a,
they make it specifically so that people
could train for hunting scenarios where
you,
you know,
you have these heavy packs on so you could
put 90 pounds on your back with these
plates and it clamps down just like
a regular barbell has a whole locking
mechanism on.
Right.
But it's a real good backpack word,
like sits on your hips and
connects in and stabilize.
It's perfectly like tuned into your,
you know,
our padded right for your
shoulders and everything.
I mean,
I'm not like,
like I said,
I'm not trying to be like
against strength conditioning,
but it's just whatever makes you happy.
Like,
I don't feel happy doing this.
And they like,
I want to do like,
yeah,
have fun with it too.
Like,
eh,
but I like manual labor,
you know,
I like digging holes.
I like getting dirty,
I like being outside kind of thing.
So,
um,
but I used to power lift like,
before I got to Colorado.
Um,
you know,
so that was a great,
um,
thing for me at the time.
And I think he's just phases.
You know,
you just do different things.
You always gotta change it up and like,
uh,
there was this,
where were you watching that one?
Uh,
weightlifting documentary where he's like,
if you can't do it dead lifts,
you know,
there's no point in living.
And I was like,
yes,
I mean dead
lifts or the Shit,
you know,
and squats and just like the basic,
like power lifting
positions or like movements.
But overall I just like
to like one training camp.
When I fought page,
I literally a the condition
or 40 conditioning exercise.
I would chase my dog for like five,
five minute rounds because she's the
fastest thing ever I could chase there.
So.
All right,
thank catcher.
I mean rocky used to chase chickens,
right?
Remember that?
I run with my dog all the time.
It's fucking dogs are in shape.
No,
we have,
we have videos of it.
It's like that's getting ready for a
fight we should do and she's chasing the
dog.
What else?
She's chasing them.
I mean,
it shouldn't be,
it shouldn't be a miserable thing,
you know,
like,
like training camp shit.
It should be hard work,
but it should also be fun.
Right.
You know,
like what,
what the hell am I doing if I'm not having
a good time doing what I love to do?
Like just for money.
Like,
no,
I want to make sure that I'm,
um,
I'm enjoying myself during these training
camps and making sure that if I didn't
have this fight,
would I still be doing this kind of thing.
I've always said that to
someone that is asked,
like,
how do I get in shape?
I said,
well,
if you take martial arts,
the beautiful thing about
it is you're getting a,
but you're having fun,
you're enjoying it,
and then you don't even realize how hard
the work is because you're having fun
and you're like getting a skill,
getting a skill,
thinking it's,
Gee,
Jujitsu and my,
this is me saying good Jujitsu
is better than lifting weights,
in my opinion.
Costco,
it because man,
just,
just heavyweight with it's,
it's slow.
So it's so much static,
whole ride.
Maybe I'm doing it wrong,
but it's so much data and when I feel
like as if when you get out of it,
because it's a fun activity because it's
interesting and it's not just 20 now.
I like doing,
I can hit a set at a
hundred curls right now.
We can,
I can I lightweights.
Right.
But good Jujitsu has been,
that's been just phenomenal man.
Just like the strength
that you can get from that.
If you're strong there,
then you're strong a lot of other places.
And when it comes to roads conditioning,
like rose,
we,
we just,
we practice functional functional
things like punching harder,
kicking harder,
grabbing the dummy and guilty eating it,
squeezing it for a ten second hold
and let negligence above a dummy.
Yeah.
Greg sounds great.
Greg Nelson would walk around with a
scream of stick on his arm and he would
just sit there and Kamora the stick
over and over again against his form and
just come more this
stick over it and over.
And we just to practice that technique.
We wondered why this is going on.
But then if he grabs your arm is,
yeah,
it's pretty hard to stop.
Well,
so the reason why my camera got so good
is because like we were literally like
shrimp up and down the Mat
shadowing like shadow boxing,
shadow grappling,
Camorra's
Gregson under appreciated guy.
He really is under appreciated guy in
the world of martial arts.
Very,
very knowledgeable guy.
Very nice guy too.
Very knowledgeable that there's,
that's,
that's one of the guys that that for
sure is one of the guys who you can ask a
question about any type of technique or
anything and not only can he give you
the answer but he can give you the
history behind it and he sits up,
this dude is a martial artists
like out of this world.
And he like it was,
it was,
it was a big deal bumping into him and
then taking everything that we've liked
that,
that she's learned from him
and then come to Denver where,
where we met Tony Bacilli
that three of the eye.
I grabbed coach and then he
took everything that all of the,
the technical things that rose learned
and took that took that to another level
to put some flavor in it.
Man,
it just took it to another level.
It's a good combination because
martial artists like very
strict and Tony's very like
very creative and just does different
movements and things that you haven't seen
before.
Well,
I'd like you both to speak to that
because it's very important to me to the
coaches that you get,
the martial arts instructors that you get,
the people that you run
into there is so critical.
It's so important.
And they should be praised.
Like if you see a guy like Matt Hume
and could create a mighty mouse,
I mean those,
those people,
they're so rare.
It's like they're so valuable and you
got to get that connection with that.
That's important to find the right fit,
find the compatibility.
And um,
so I think that's why you see some people
bouncing around because it's just lay
down really vibe with this place,
you know,
or you don't vibe with
the community though.
The town that you're in,
you know,
maybe you don't want to live in this city.
And so you try all
Denver for a little bit,
or maybe maybe Milwaukee is your spot.
You know,
it's like there's so many different
alternatives and there's so many different
styles that people have.
Like for some people,
you know,
American top team would be
the spot for some people,
you know,
maybe they should try Montreal
and go up to see for us a hobby.
You know,
it's,
we're so fortunate now,
I think that there's so many places to
choose from where you can you go to John
crunched down in Arizona,
you know,
he'd go to the lab,
you can go to,
you know,
Duke Roufus in Milwaukee,
you can go,
there's so many places now.
It's so,
it's amazing to find your flavor.
Like there's,
there's some places where you go,
there's some gyms that you go to in the,
the,
the training of the gym consists of
who shows up to practice that day.
And it's just like,
all right,
everybody,
we're working on single legs
and just go and just find,
you know what I mean?
So you get better based on who showed up,
like all your teammates I showed up.
And then there's,
there's the coaches where
they're very one on one ish.
Like Matt human created a Demetrius
Johnson like Trevor Whitman is,
is,
is good enough to take an individual
and make them an individual versus all
right,
everyone in the room,
we're all going to throw
this one job and that's it.
Like he's very,
very specific and can make,
he can,
he can find what you're good at
and help you become an individual,
like I say in the gym.
Yeah.
And maybe his style is
perfectly matched for you and,
but it might not be perfectly
matched for somebody else.
And it's,
it's such an interesting relationship
between trainers and fighters.
And um,
and the,
it really bums me out is how
sometimes fighters forget it.
Just forget what got them
there and they forget.
They think it's all about them.
And it's such a selfish sport and a lot
of ways because it's really only you in
there.
Yeah.
I mean they like,
I mean,
they've been in so many training camps,
like literally pat has a,
a meniscus surgery that
he needs to get fixed,
you know,
and it's like they go,
they beat up their bodies
just as much as we do to yeah.
To train with us.
And I especially in,
um,
in my situation where it
is like fight handling it,
it is like very,
um,
one on one kind of a deal where it's
not like I have hundreds of training
partners and I go to this,
you know,
like att for example,
they have like hundreds
of people there and,
um,
you know,
like I just have these guys,
so,
right.
Yeah.
So it's good to appreciate your coaching.
It really is,
you know,
really is.
It's,
um,
it's a,
it's such an unusual relationship,
the relationship between
a fighter and a coach.
It's a,
yeah.
I mean,
like I,
once I,
once I finally,
um,
you know,
once I finally went through kind of
just my different learning lessons,
like after I fought Caroline,
I didn't have him in my corner.
And like,
after,
like I realize that was,
you know,
the missing link and we,
it's just something that I've realized,
you know,
if I can't do it with these guys
and I don't want to do it no more,
you know,
cause it's just,
it's all about being happy.
It's all about,
um,
what makes you happy.
I mean,
you ever notice how like kids never get
tired or like they can just run around
in circles for forever and it's
because they're having fun doing it.
And so that's the,
that's where the training is based,
is like,
whatever it takes,
she happy.
Now when you look at
your future and you say,
I'm the champ now,
do you have a roadmap that you have?
Like,
I want to retire in 10 years,
I want to get this,
I want to accomplish these things.
Do you have anything like that or you just
my,
yeah,
like I,
I like to have a plan and then
if things change and you know,
that's fine.
You know,
you have to be able to adapt.
Um,
I plan on not fighting longer
than five years from now.
I know.
Yeah.
How old are you now?
25 so 30 that's a wrap.
Yeah.
I don't want to,
if any of my thoughts,
I mean,
I could,
you know,
by the time that comes around,
like,
like time flies.
Like I could be their
ears old and be like,
fuck yeah.
Well it's also,
oh,
you have the potential to
be a fucking huge star.
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't want to freak you out,
but you're,
you're this journey.
You're a very unique person and
you're this very strange time in,
in history where it's,
I don't want us to freak you out,
but I think the sport
needs someone like you.
Yeah.
I really think your unique perspective
or a very unique individual and I think
that perspective,
I think we can help a lot of
people to recognize that there's a,
there's a,
a broad spectrum of people out there that
are doing this and that your genuine,
you're genuine behavior and thought
process and how in depth your thought
process is.
I think it's very,
it's very important
right now.
I think it is important,
especially for women too and you know,
cause uh,
to have a tendency to be pretty
catty and bitchy towards each other.
And I think that,
um,
if I can show an example to other women
to be more loving to each other and not
just,
you know,
a woman to woman but to
each other man or woman,
it just,
it's,
uh,
I think it's important.
Um,
it also,
the way you shave your head,
you wearing sweat pants,
you don't give a fuck
that,
but you're still beautiful.
I mean that's an important in
Europe also beautiful person,
like your personality
and I think that that's,
that's so that's so needed right now.
Thank you.
It was always like,
like in,
in,
in time,
there's always dark times and
there's light times as dark times.
And we've been,
uh,
in the world in general
for the last few years,
it's been kind of,
things have been kind of whack.
People are wearing more
sunglasses at night,
the fighters are getting more ridiculous.
It's just,
yeah.
And I feel like as if,
not that we've hit a seriously low point,
but things have gotten pretty whack.
And I have the feeling that
after that performance,
like after what she did
and when she said that,
that was like a spark of the
beginning of things coming,
coming,
coming back,
coming back up.
Like just things being a
little bit more not so,
like not so fucking ridiculous.
Like I said,
everybody's got their sunglasses on,
everybody's showing up with a leather
jacket with no shirt on under it.
Everybody's,
everybody's like talking crazy
shit and just being ridiculous,
man.
Well,
Connor kind of changed the game.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
I mean the time to let everybody
know how valuable shit talking is now
everybody's gonna be wearing these pants.
Yeah.
So,
I mean it's,
it's,
it seemed to me,
I mean this is,
uh,
just my take on it.
I feel like the UFC missed
out with Amanda Nunez.
They,
they,
when they were marketing
Ronda Rousey for that fight,
first of all,
I was looking at it,
I was like,
this is all Ronda Rousey
and she is facing,
in my opinion,
the worst possible matchup.
Brazilian Jujitsu,
black belt who hits like
a fucking truck and uh,
a real tested warrior.
Yeah.
He didn't get promoted.
They didn't promote it.
They may,
they promoted the Ronda Rousey thing,
the Ronda Rousey comeback back and her
walking around her mansion frowning.
Like she's coming back,
she's coming back to
fight a fucking killer.
Yeah.
And why not promote the killer?
Like this woman is Merkin people,
the group,
what she did to me should take a
look at what she's doing to people.
She's blasting people into
orbit and then she wins.
And you have this opportunity of the very
first gay woman who is a mixed martial
arts UFC champion first,
first one ever.
Right.
This is not no big,
no big push.
Yeah.
But that also could mean from what,
from what we've just discovered over the
last three months that it could also be
Amanda though.
Like we left New York that
night and no one talk.
Nothing was different for two months,
Bro.
Yeah,
but we created that
ourselves when we did that.
We went home and we looked out the window
for two months trying to figure out
who's walking down the street.
I mean we,
we,
we shut it down.
They want it rose to instantly going
to a victory tour across New York.
They want us to stay in New York like
after that whole week in New York,
they,
after the fight they say,
we want you to stay in New York.
Do you won a victory tour?
And I,
I had to,
I was like,
no way.
Absolutely not.
We have to go,
we have to leave.
We're not only do we have to leave,
we're leaving right now to think that
there was some benefit in doing a victory
tour of doing a bunch
of different television.
I,
no,
no.
I feel like I might have like I don't
know what I would have even said in the
interviews at that time cause it was just
like still processing [inaudible] been
a good time.
But I think that's one of the things
that people would like to see.
You try to process it.
Yeah I know
people want to do it.
They were going to see rose do this.
But I,
I honestly think
in that circumstance it's
critical who you talk to.
Yeah.
Cause you can be talking to some fucking
normal morning show dummy and then I'll
give a shit about the sport and they're
going to ask you stupid questions.
You're only on for five minutes.
You're like,
well you know,
hey it all worked out.
Hey
thank you know a wave at the camera.
But looking back in hindsight,
I wish I could have like a took it in a
little bit more but it was kind of like,
okay,
next fight.
Like you know what I mean?
It's just like everything is there.
Then we were like,
okay let's get out of here.
And we,
the we,
we all,
we,
we stood up,
we shook hands and we said,
everybody knows everybody would be cool.
We just got to get the
fuck we got to get home.
I got to say,
I like it
that too though.
Yeah.
I liked that approach to
get the fuck out of dot.
Yeah.
Like,
so,
so in our entire relationship,
like pet has had to learn this over time,
that like if I get,
uh,
the instinct to rose,
you got to really need a bus out.
Like I,
you have to listen to me.
Like,
now's the time to go.
You know,
like,
I'll just get this feeling.
I'm like,
something will happen.
Like we're leaving occurrences
who's,
his intuition has been spot on a,
Yo,
we gotta get the fuck
out of here right now.
And we're like,
all right,
cool.
So there's no question.
And now there's no question anymore.
If Rose said right now we out we dry,
we really,
we call it a,
everybody knows it's a countdown and Rosay
let's bounce ten nine and we're going
to launch the last time she did this,
wait,
we gotta get the Fuck Outta here.
We were leaving.
There was the,
one of the first times we
had going out to a nightclub,
they're like,
we've been saying for three years.
Then like eventually Valentino,
like one her fight in Denver.
So we're like,
what you going?
I go outside,
I will,
will you want to do it?
We're going to do it.
Then we went out to,
again,
it was fun and we danced and for years
we haven't gone to anytime it doesn't,
we danced,
it was great and everybody had a great
time and then all of a sudden out of
nowhere,
1231 row says,
you know,
we got it.
Let's get the fuck Outta here.
And it's instant is the instant change
of the feeling around one o'clock.
Or if somebody say,
look,
we gotta get the Fuck Outta here.
And within,
within a minute we had
eight people were grabbing.
People come with this,
let's go,
let's go from the gym.
How you getting home?
Come with us like the get in the van and
we walked through the down the stairs
past this really big guy that was by
the front door arguing with the security
guy,
right?
Pessoa excuse me sir.
Right past him.
And as soon as we got past him he
started shooting everybody pop,
pop,
pop.
Like he just started shooting everybody.
Wow.
It's been,
it's been instances
like this where Rosanne,
where the gun was going off,
pop,
pop out.
And then not only that,
but we got in the van and everybody
fucking don't move the dude,
they,
he walked to the car that was
parked right in front of us.
Like we were parked like
this chick where in the van,
the Schick runs up to the door.
She's scrambling trying to get
in his guys casually walking.
We don't know what's going on.
He just casually walking around.
We just see this guy.
He opens up the door,
pulls a gun out.
She was,
oh,
shoots her.
No,
no,
no.
She's old.
She was living
Nicola,
she was having an argument
with the doorman I think.
Yeah.
Because they weren't letting
him in or something like that.
So he's just started shooting pow,
POW,
pow.
And then he walked to his car and
then when he got his coat he said,
Huh,
put the gun up again.
He hit him more to do and then got in
the car and they just casually drove off.
[inaudible] that we're on is like,
I,
yeah,
I like,
I will call it like instantly.
Like you just think you
have very good intuition.
Just seen stuff like that,
you know?
Like I,
I will,
I just can feel the energy
of a room like change,
like,
um,
you know,
when I was a kid and we was
just playing basketball and,
and it's like,
it's weird how nobody
else will pick up on it.
Like,
except for myself,
you know?
Um,
in those situations,
like I was playing basketball with my
friends and then like down the street,
I thought I heard something
in a distance that like,
you know,
just people talking,
but it,
or some like people making noises.
But I didn't,
you know,
there's,
there's always nice,
we're in the middle of the city,
you know,
but for some reason my attention
was brought to this noise,
like it's something's wrong.
So I look and I'm like,
and I think I see some people
wrestling over there or something.
And then you know,
my friends like,
oh no,
it's probably,
they're probably cool.
What are you talking about?
And I was like,
I'm gonna go over there and check it out.
And it's like,
uh,
you know,
run across the street
a couple blocks down.
And then like also,
and I see a guy have
a knife and stabs him,
you know,
and then he falls down and he like
turns towards me and then I'm like,
oh shit.
You know,
so and then I realized that my,
my little like,
dude,
that I,
that I would like help
raise like as a kid,
cause he was like young as,
as well as myself,
I think it was Matthew.
And then I saw him follow me over here.
And so I thought it was the only one.
So I was like,
Oh shit,
I'm happy you go home.
You know,
like,
so we had the run and then he ended
up just driving off or whatever.
I don't know if they
found the guy or whatever,
but um
hmm.
Rosa says shit,
like we're on the highway
driving on a road trip.
She's like,
get off right here.
Like just quick get over it.
You go to start getting off in the car,
flips over.
It's spooky.
I don't question it.
I don't question it anymore.
And then it just like,
you know,
just like the whole thing with the,
with the truck driving an accident,
like that type of stuff.
Like it's just seems like,
I dunno,
like,
and that's why I always believed,
believed in the fact that if you're
delayed or you're late for something,
it's for a reason.
You know?
And so that's why I was like the week
of the fight I was like in nervous cause
it was like,
oh,
we're gonna get there late and you know,
it was going to be all,
you know,
things are starting to go wrong already.
And then once we landed,
I kind of like put,
put the pieces together like,
oh yeah,
that's,
that's why everything
happens for a reason.
So do you,
you always feel like you're kind of
tuned in to something that other people
aren't tuned into?
Um,
it depends on where I'm at in my life.
Like sometimes if I'm,
if I'm living the right way,
if I'm healthy,
if I'm like,
you know,
in shape or if I'm,
spiritually,
right.
Yeah.
Like a troubled,
like if I'm surrounding myself,
if I'm making the wrong choices of
I'm surrounding myself around like,
you know,
just evil and stuff.
Like if I'm,
uh,
just like the wrong people,
you're trouble,
then I won't have like,
confused.
Yeah.
Then it's hard to make
clear decisions or like,
yeah.
Or to have good intuition.
Yeah.
So if you're free of any regret
or remorse of your own actions,
you're more clearly,
you can discern what's going
on in your environment.
Right.
And that's why I say like
very,
very super observant.
I mean just coming up with a,
and it's almost like a,
I would say just from the stories that
I've heard of the growing up in the past,
um,
uh,
because of those experiences,
she got a really like a really good,
a really good at scoping out a room,
you know what I mean?
Like really like nothing can,
like,
it's really hard to sneak up on rose.
She sees you coming from two days ago.
Like it's just,
it's really,
it's,
it's uh,
she's very observant.
I said,
let's say that and in a way because of,
because of growing up,
it's,
it's a skill that had to be developed.
You snuck up on me once.
I don't ever happen again.
Right.
As kids,
like,
you know,
people that I used to
like hang out with on the,
uh,
in my neighborhood,
we would help each other out.
Like we would teach each other like,
yeah,
I don't go down that place or don't
hang out over there because somebody got
shot over there.
Like,
you know,
like the same car,
like circles around this
block too many times.
Like go inside,
you know,
kind of thing.
Yeah.
How hard is it to watch each other fight
when he was fighting?
It was pretty hard for me.
But then when I was actually there when
he had a kickboxing fight and I was
actually able to be in his corner,
I felt a lot better.
But,
uh,
being away at home,
that was difficult for me.
And also because she knew
internally I wasn't ready.
Yeah.
Well,
I guess that's not all the time,
but yeah,
that's also the big part of it.
Like,
I could have been more ready
for the majority of the
fights that rose was around
for what was wrong with me.
Yeah,
no,
I meant just fighting for
the wrong reasons and,
uh,
just not,
not necessarily going about
it in the healthiest way.
I mean,
I had a prescription pill problem.
The whiskey was delicious.
I mean,
just,
just living,
living in the living,
not that,
not the healthiest life
and not the best life.
Like,
like I said,
I was doing,
I was doing it for the wrong reasons.
Like there was a when and I met,
I said,
um,
uh,
you are,
you are good enough to
be a world champion.
You're good enough to be the best in
the world and this is something that you
really want to do.
I'll make sure you never
have to have a job.
All you have to do is train.
If this is something that
you really want to do,
I'll make sure you never have
to work a day in your life.
All you have to do is train
and be a fighter and that's it.
So as soon as that started,
um,
I kind of,
I caught myself getting into fights
asking how much does this one pay?
25 and 25 all right,
cool.
I can do some math on if I
went into just another loose.
All right,
cool.
Just get into the fight.
She lost.
I don't give a fuck how much.
Like I,
I find myself getting a uncontrollably
getting into that scenario now.
The kickbox and message she was at,
I was ready for that.
Like I actually was,
was passed all that,
a shitty decision making that I was
making a and and was actually prepped for
that woman.
But there were other times where
whether it be conscious or not,
subconsciously there
was somewhere inside of,
I would guess the mind where
we both knew that I wasn't,
I hadn't done,
I'm supposed to do 10
but no one's looking.
So I only did eight and it just
didn't say anything you want.
I mean like that type of thing.
Do you have regret?
No,
no,
no.
Never.
And the reason why is because if
I go back and change anything,
I won't be sitting here
talking to you right now.
You don't like every
decision that I've made,
every life experience that I've had dad
passing away when I was a kid having to
do all these different,
like all of the decisions that I've made
and all of the trials and tribulations
that I've been through have been exactly
why I'm sitting here right now with the
beautiful woman right next to me who
happens to be a world champion talking to
Joe Rogan.
And,
you know,
I've learned a lot of
lessons from his mistakes,
you know,
like,
or an his,
his successes as well,
you know,
just watching him.
Um,
yeah,
it goes through all that is,
it's helped me a lot.
Yeah.
No regrets.
It's almost like I've been able to
experiment with having a UFC career,
but not actually having to like do it,
you know,
like living vicariously through him
and then now I can know what I can do.
Dip.
It's like doing it all over again.
When did you decide to stop pat?
I have still not,
he's still not,
no.
No,
I'm not.
I'm never going to,
okay.
This is this,
this doesn't have to be a belief
that everybody believes in,
but I believe that if you're a fighter,
you don't really retire.
You'd ever really retire until
people just stop giving you fights.
I'm never going to want to stay.
I'm,
I'm always one to want to fight.
Always.
Always,
always.
The last time you fought,
man,
two years ago.
Was it in glory?
Yeah.
Uh,
no.
This was like
no legacy.
I think it fuck Demori Demario
Dennis who was maybe my last fight,
the last kickboxing match I think,
um,
I think that was it like two years ago.
But like I still want to fight now.
I have a,
uh,
have a,
a lateral meniscus tear
that I would like to get.
I need for this,
for,
for just my own happiness and for roses
training camp I need to get done with
like take care of that because that puts
a lot of hindrance on training after
all these years.
As soon as the knee starts feeling weird,
oh,
automatic lease.
Just take it easy and just
don't fuck with it too much.
But the tear that can be fixed with stem
cells or is it something that has to be
done with the a scope
I think needs a scope.
We are just finding out about stem cells
is a question I was going to ask you.
How do you feel about that?
Like,
uh,
I would,
you know,
and he did what you told me before,
but I'm a big believer in it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I'm sure it does some
pretty miraculous shit.
If you use it correctly
and you get a good doctor.
Yeah.
So I'm looking at for Dr.
Davidson from the UFC.
Yes.
Yeah.
Talk to him about it.
He's,
well,
he's who I talked to her,
I called him kind of in a,
we have 11 left.
Were you 11 weeks off from the fight?
[inaudible] I would like to call myself
one a roses main training partners and
it would be cool if I can get this need
taken care of either this week or next
week at the latest so I can have the
few weeks off of recovery and still have
seven weeks left to attack every day.
You know what I mean?
Like,
like in order for us to do that.
But do I want to fight again?
Yeah,
absolutely.
I'm always gonna want to
[inaudible] I got to
fight all over yesterday.
Hell No.
Hell no,
no,
no.
Hell No.
But I will,
I fight again.
No idea.
Roses,
roses,
the star of the show though,
you know,
like,
Nah,
it has to be like the right thing,
you know,
like it has to be,
everything has to me,
right?
Oh,
I think it was going to be like on a
Sunday at the county fair or sounds like
that.
Pedro,
his own man,
he's a guy who's been around a long,
a long time.
He's been in some war a long time,
but I got off of that now.
I said,
no thank you,
but I'm still,
I'm still getting the calls every once
in a while for not as much as you to say
no thank you.
Because it was about offer.
No,
no,
no.
Well,
I don't know.
Not,
not,
not good timing.
And this is an MMA fighter
or a kickboxing fight,
man.
I think it was going to be a
kickboxing match with MMA gloves on,
I think.
I Dunno.
But I also had another
fight with Eric Prindle.
Those supposed to be November 18th,
that that was a kickboxing match
with the MMA gloves on I think.
And um,
that one got postponed,
which,
which was totally,
completely great.
Light rose is the shit.
Yeah.
I'm not getting,
I'm not getting in the way of that,
like roses fucking rolling right now.
I am calm.
I,
I'm,
I'm embracing the role of,
of a coach and team leader now and not
being the athlete anymore and I get it.
I know I'm 38 now.
Whatever the fuck is going on with,
with me,
which things are a lot better now.
Uh,
I'm,
I'm healthy and everything's great,
but rose is where it's at.
Like that's where my attention,
my time and attention
has been since we met,
since we met.
And it's still going to be that way.
Like roses,
roses,
I'm gonna I,
I said when we met,
I was gonna make it a point.
You will be,
you,
you have what it takes to be the best,
I'm going to make sure of it,
you know,
like that,
that that's the role that I like,
that's the role that I liked.
Now it's a lot more comfortable now.
Oven baked pizza every fucking night.
Like I love it.
Like it's,
it's more comfortable now for me to
do that now at the exact same time.
It drives me crazy that I'm not fighting.
You just got to have a,
a good purpose,
but how much you're doing,
you know?
It's just like the,
the bottom line,
you know,
whatever you want to do,
you can do anything that you want to do.
What was your reasoning?
Right.
And um,
for me at this point
is to change the world.
Like I know it's a little freshman
reasoning is to change the world.
Yeah.
Really?
How so?
This is like my,
this is the my best,
uh,
skill am I bet.
Like the thing that I can
do the best and I think it,
it,
it reaches a lot of a big audience.
Um,
and I can get my message across.
Yeah.
And um,
you know,
like you were saying like it
just sat in a better example,
trying to,
um,
change the way people think or I leaches
offering a different perspective,
you know,
got to think like me,
um,
is this is an active idea.
It's in your head.
Like while you're training,
while you're doing media,
you thinking,
I have a chance to change the world.
I want to,
um,
build a urban farm in my community and
I want to make it available for like
other people that,
cause the way that I grew up.
I wish there was like an urban farm where
I could learn how to grow my own food
and I could get my own food that
was not from the grocery store,
you know.
Um,
and so I want to provide
that for other people and,
you know,
finds the best,
the quickest way I can do that.
And I think,
you know,
and there's other ways,
like,
yeah,
for example,
um,
I started getting into like some
crypto currencies and stuff and,
um,
there's this thing called
Evergreen coin that's just like,
you know,
one of the alt coins,
whoever,
I don't know,
it's,
it's still a pretty small whatever,
but it's,
it's a,
so like it's a sustainable
cryptocurrency that,
um,
it doesn't,
it doesn't use as much electricity
and it kind of goes into every kind of
philosophy that I agree upon.
You know,
it feels,
it falls in line with my beliefs and it,
um,
there's just a lot of aspects
about it that I really like.
And so that's something that like you get,
um,
you can,
it's good for charities.
So like if you hold some evergreen coin,
like you can,
um,
get some stock in it from,
I mean,
I sound kind of stupid trying
to recite all this information,
but yeah,
like you just,
you can generate money with it and then
you can donate it to charity and it
works that way.
Okay.
So these are just a,
a bunch of different things that you
would like to let people know about and
help people understand.
Yeah.
And I'm still formulating these ideas,
you know,
obviously like,
cause I mean,
fighting takes up all your time,
you know,
but I like to think about these
things and I think it just,
you know,
over time it,
it's just kind of like
kind of fall into place,
you know,
just doing things like,
the Indonesia earthship trip and like
just doing different stuff that I can,
um,
build skills for later.
And you're going to do more of
this on your Youtube Channel?
Yeah,
I'm trying to,
um,
I've been trying to now as a chapter,
it seems like a great idea.
Yeah.
I've been trying to put
together the next episode.
I have a whole bunch of footage.
Um,
so
like,
sorry guys.
It seems like something
I want to get involved,
like some sort of a production
company or something.
I mean,
it seems like a no brainer to me.
Yeah.
I've got a camera guy,
Austin,
Eric,
and who,
you know,
he does a great job and um,
it's just been,
it's just been kind of a roller coaster,
you know,
all this traveling or just,
trying to get things together
and get my shit together.
Will we also have to shut it down and
put it on pause after the Michelle fight?
Yeah.
After Michelle Waterson
fight however long ago,
that was,
as soon as that was over with,
we knew Yolanda was next and we,
everything stopped.
Social media kind just got off of like
that for a little while and not off of it
completely,
but just trying to like minimize
it and because I knew that well,
um,
I think it,
you know,
I dunno,
it's,
it's the,
the most addictive drug,
you know,
like just being on your phone and you
just fill your head up with just like a
whole bunch of information that like when
you're focused on just this one person
and like to defeat this person,
this one mission,
it's hard to,
you know,
like you only have so much room in
your head for that kind of stuff.
And also because we knew you ana was
checking her Instagram every day.
Yeah,
it was driver does,
it would drive her crazy to not
post anything or be seen anywhere.
Like,
um,
it's,
it's uh,
she even said in the interview,
she's like,
she don't want to do social
media and stuff is like,
like,
I mean like why does it bother you?
Like understand like
she couldn't see you,
she had no idea what you looked like.
She does training.
She did send doing any of that offense.
It probably,
she had paper view points.
Yeah.
So she had a,
she had a great reasoning to do it,
but part of the strategy going
into this fight was to go see you,
Ana.
That was,
that was a big,
that was a factor.
That was a big part of this
game plan was to ghost had,
no matter what she says,
no matter what she does,
and we knew that it was
going to come and level.
She's going to say this,
then she's going to say this,
then she's going to save this.
Then she's going to talk about your dog.
Like it's just gonna.
It's gonna get bigger
and bigger and bigger.
And she might even,
we even knew she was going to touch you.
She's gonna push you.
She's going to touch you when she does.
Don't move,
don't react given nothing.
Give her nothing.
And it worked.
Now she knows though,
the g
and I'm going to be starting phase.
I mean,
she's the big mega,
don't believe in,
you know,
like,
I mean,
go.
Don't put a hex on her.
She's gonna,
she's gonna.
She's coming mega bogies coming,
she's going to be,
I love it.
You know,
I don't,
I don't hate on her for doing it.
She's doing,
you know,
it's just,
it's kind of like silly,
you know,
to me.
But um,
but it was great,
you know,
like without right.
Without her and without my
contrast and personality,
that fight wouldn't have been
nearly as exciting as it was,
you know?
So like we need,
I need her and that's why I think I like
to get people to understand like other
fighters,
like you need your opponent just as much
as you need your training partners and
your teammates and your coaches,
you know,
like is your dancing
partner like it's a show,
you know,
and it's awesome,
but it's real to,
you know?
Yeah.
It's also what gets you up.
Gets you fired up.
I the to fight a woman
that's that dangerous.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Yo,
Yo.
Hey Yo.
So she told rose some crazy like,
okay,
so I'm all week shit was going on.
We missed the car accident,
we missed the ant.
Like the Antifa thing
happened right in front of us.
Uh,
we got down to the locker room and they
gave rose the wrong gloves and didn't
want to give her the right gloves
like Dave or the wrong gloves.
What do you mean by the wrong gloves?
Uh,
I need like a bantamweight
sides glove and it gave me a,
they gave a straw way going
somewhere specifically before hand.
Yeah.
She got broken fingers.
This was going on.
I knew that these are piano playing hands.
Yeah.
We've got to the arena late.
Like usually you get to the
arena and you have three hours.
Right.
But you were just going to say something.
You stopped yourself.
You said she was,
she said something to rose.
Yeah.
So I would get to like,
we got,
we got to the regional late.
They gave him the wrong gloves,
they played the wrong walkout music like,
and walk out music.
I have no idea.
It was something terrible.
I was so mad.
Who is mostly come out too?
Well,
so originally,
what was it?
It was we freedom.
I switched it to that all week long.
I was like,
cause I want to something uplifting,
something happy,
you know,
and and I was something that we've been
jamming out to for like a few weeks or
whatever.
And um,
the whole week I would
tell him how I'm like,
I can't wait until late
playing my walkout song.
It's just all I care about.
They fostered that song.
So
he actually came out to do you know,
I have no use like some oasis.
I don't know.
It was like someone make a decision
or did they fuck up till now?
I try it.
I think somebody told me
that there was a mistake.
I'm sorry,
Dickhead who loves oasis so
you don't miss the old year.
What I want to hear man,
I mean it's just such a contrast thing,
like style and be like,
ah,
I didn't even know how
you can make that mistake.
Like oh whatever.
Be the best part,
the best part of the week.
Because by the time that
happened it was like,
ah,
fuck it.
Fucking everything,
man.
It's fucking man.
It's crazy.
What will you going to say
that she said you want to,
you don't want to be for the fight came
like they you do on the EU side of drug
testing,
uh,
roses walking back through the hallway
with her official as she crossed paths
with Ilana and all by herself.
And you want to go ahead?
Oh yeah.
She like in a different tone of voice too,
like the weirdness,
like she didn't seem
like herself for a sec.
I mean,
I'm sure it is getting in fight mode or
whatever and it's just like breaking in
her gloves and you see like,
and that gave her like the US up,
you know?
And she gave me the what's
up and then she was like,
I'm just like,
I think she asked me something like,
cause you buy the ticket.
All right.
I was like,
she's like,
do you believe him or
do you believe in them?
Or something like that.
Do you believe him?
Did you buy the ticket?
Yeah.
And then she walked off
and didn't say no and I was just like,
uh,
it was like,
wow.
Did you buy the test?
She's Kaiser Sosa.
Yes.
His Dad to do that like all week long way.
Even in the
no way in,
you know,
after the way ins this of
like all kinds of stuff.
I'm fucking shit right back to the
locker room now we're ready all week.
We've been deflecting shit.
We've been deflecting shit now roses,
a very emotional person template.
Like she's,
we got to keep rolling.
Keep rolling straight cause she comes
in with the wrong look on her face.
Something's wrong.
She goes off and does the
drug testing comes back.
And when she sat down she
sits down and he says,
we have to,
we have to have a meeting now that's cold.
We have to have a meeting.
Is Code for,
shut it down.
Everybody get the fuck out.
We were bouncing.
We have to have a meeting is like kind
of another way of saying start the
countdown.
We're leaving.
We have to have a meeting.
And when she said that,
the way she said it,
I mean everything came over me like,
oh fuck.
Well what happened?
And then when she said,
would you wanna sit in the back?
What do you want to told her?
Do you believe him?
Did you buy the ticket and then left
without any explanation?
Yo,
when wrote,
when Rose said that to me,
my fucking head exploded it and
the only thing I could say was,
ah,
shit,
I don't want to have to fucking
think about this all night.
Oh
Man.
You know she's been notable time world
champion and she just knows how to fuck
with people,
Bro.
We deflected everything.
We deflected the knuckles in the mouth
in the crazy shit that she was saying,
ticket everything.
And if she came and said that
when we got back to Louisiana,
just five minutes
delayed or,
or
for,
for a good three,
four minutes for three or four minutes,
Trevor,
Tony Rose and I all sat
in the locker room just
because,
because that was the little,
that was the little thing that could
have fucked everything up because I know.
What does that mean?
Did you buy the two?
Cause they're email,
she says,
do you believe him?
But you had to know it was horse shit.
Right?
You had to know what she was doing.
Like if you ran into someone at the
fucking seven 11 and they said something
like that's crazy asshole.
It'd be out of your head in a minute.
But she said it with a calm
voice and then just walked off.
No accent,
no accent.
Just said it just said it real common
like to the point where there's,
there's even a chance
and I think this one there's
even a chance that you want it.
No recollection of nowhere.
Maybe she,
I don't know man.
I was just like red
roses be spooky sometimes
like so there's a chance that like just
with the way the whole week when that
maybe that was let's say God or a
higher being or something like that.
Maybe that was the last test.
Do you fucking believe him?
Did you buy the ticket and then just
walked off was that was a test of whether
or not
we're going to get all the way down to
right here and you're going to be fucked
in the head.
Now knew by the way,
this is after the facts re
re mastering the system.
By the way,
like in a moment,
something inside of me.
I was like,
I don't know what she's talking about,
but just gave her the thumbs up like yeah,
I'm a fuck.
I believe in him.
Like I don't know what
you're talking about.
Yeah.
Hey Yo man,
we didn't know we were in the locker
room and really rose had to get up to go
and do something over there and when she
got over there I turned to Trevor and
Tony said,
hey y'all,
we in some,
oh fuck.
Oh fuck.
It's so crazy.
That one little silly thing.
Yeah.
She's just trying to fuck with your head.
Right.
That actually works.
Got Three minutes.
We will amazing the shit like that works.
It's just like a little mind fuck yes.
Yeah.
How,
what ticket?
I mean cause it's like my believing,
right?
Yeah,
she's a wizard.
Yeah.
Hey,
when she came back and said that shit,
I said they start thing.
I was like,
what did I do now do
you think at all about,
you don't think at all about
doing that back to her.
I mean you just fucked
her up in the first round.
So what do you say that I did it like
I did fuck her up and I had though,
you definitely did you fuck me up
and I was about to interview you.
I'm like,
she got this thousand
yard stare and she's,
and I was like,
what were you saying?
And you're like,
I was saying the Lord's prayer.
I was like,
oh Jesus Christ.
Right there was like
the devil and a priest.
I was like,
the two of you together.
It was like,
and she was like saying
she was the Boogie,
it was one of my favorite
stare downs and the buildup,
the way you handled it was
very interesting because
most people handled it.
They'd get in her face too.
Fuck you bitch.
Claudia and her would get together.
And I think that emotional,
like the conflict and all the,
the extra energy that's involved in that,
like he,
it fucks with people's heads.
Right,
right.
And that's what she's looking for.
I think I over you on his career.
She came in as a silent killer
who's destroying everybody
and then she found out
that if I start talking shit to someone,
they get fucked in the head
before the fight even happens.
And then it worked and
worked and it worked.
So he got to the point where she's that,
that,
that almost,
that one weapon right there almost
replaced some of the ferociousness in,
in,
in her fighting maybe.
Yeah.
Like,
like knowing that end,
that why is also why the game plan was,
was to go see Awana no
matter what happens.
Like we know that she needs a reaction.
She's looking for something,
no pictures,
no videos,
no social media,
no interviews,
no nothing.
And when she says something,
don't even look at it.
Just like she doesn't exist.
Just ghost.
It goes to the entire time.
We know for a fact that even
before we were signed up to fight,
she's thinking about me.
You know,
like she knew I was on
the radar of course.
A long time.
Yeah,
of course you have to be.
Yeah.
I mean,
there's a handful of contenders in the
strawweight division and you are at the
top of the heap and especially
after you beat Michelle,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's how we knew it.
So no social media,
no nothing.
We just,
we just don't,
no,
it was just
feels better,
you know,
like not having to do all that,
but I mean
on you to try to do that kind of shit.
No,
they,
they did,
but we sold,
honestly said not this time
that they just understood.
Yeah.
We've very honestly said,
no,
that's not me.
That's not going to work out for us.
We need to,
we need to prepare for this fight
and we need to be all the way ready.
Now there's of course there's some
interviews that need to be done,
but the other,
like the other little things,
like how come you not posting about them?
I mean,
not re tweeting this picture,
it's like,
nope,
not,
no.
It'd be hilarious if you did a bunch
of shit that had nothing to do with the
fight.
Like almost like,
you know,
even fighting,
right.
It's found a cool Indian restaurant.
I know.
Seriously.
Oh,
I love this movie.
It's Hilarious,
right?
No pad hitting,
no shit talk and the
motivational speeches,
I mean,
because really like,
I think you should like show other
sides of you other than just like,
I think I get kind of just bored,
just posting and other group
picture and other like,
oh,
this is what I'm eating today.
Or you know,
like here,
this is my workout today.
I don't know.
I mean some of the word goals
is definitely to be watched.
Like we got some cool footage,
uh,
hiding away.
But
did you post that stuff after the fight
or do you think that any of the stuff
that you post,
like on workout footage,
training footage,
especially like working on technique,
do you think that in any way
that helps people read you?
I don't know cause it's totally different
standing across from me in the ring,
you know what I mean?
Like I could train,
I mean I trained with teacher's door is,
you know,
like,
and we fought each other.
We've lived in the same house together,
like for multiple weeks.
You know,
and I'll still fight her again.
You know what I mean?
So it's like,
it's not,
it's,
you can't,
I mean there's things you can pick up.
Yeah.
But I'm gonna change it up on you.
I always got another ace in my pocket,
you know?
Yeah.
I like to,
I don't,
I don't know.
I keep everything to myself,
you know,
like I said,
you want to give,
you know,
sure.
Training.
The,
the,
the challenge.
So it's so,
uh,
it's so barely different,
but,
but it is still different how you
can train together all day and night.
But when the bell rings for a fight,
it's totally different.
Yes.
You ever hear,
you ever hear,
uh,
stories of clay,
Guido and the gym and
at practice he can't.
They appear.
We,
we've been hearing for years.
I played,
we had a good,
it just gets thrown around
at the gym all day and night,
but when he gets in the
rink and fight like a Mazda,
like we've like,
there are,
they can,
they can train together all day and night,
but when it comes five time,
it's just,
it's just different.
Huh.
Funny my ability that I'm
really good at what I do,
you know?
And it's just,
it makes it more fun to share
it with people and like,
you know,
but I want to give all my secrets away.
You know,
he had to keep making up new ones,
you know.
Um,
well listen rose,
I'm happier out there
cause you a lot of fun.
I really enjoy calling your fights
and I really did enjoy that whole,
the whole week,
all the press conferences and your,
your behavior.
And I think to this day,
like I said,
after your fight,
that post fight speech was my,
one of my all time favorites.
Yeah,
thank you.
It was awesome.
And it was very genuine,
you know,
and I think you guys have
an awesome relationship.
It's very cool.
It's very cool to see you guys and how
much he cares about you and the way you
guys work together.
It's,
it's fucking awesome.
Yeah.
Hopefully we can,
uh,
maybe not make the on Lisa again,
but you know,
making the,
and called,
we called Dana White
and told them after the,
when they were asking for the next fight,
they're trying to get
us out of the contract.
We told him that she won the belt,
so we were going to start a family.
She wanted the belt.
So we're going to start a family and now
he'd come back in a few years and then
did he say they didn't like that at all?
It was like,
Nah,
man,
just kit
April 7th paper view.
I'm going to be there and I can't wait.
Thank you,
Pat Barry.
Thank you rose.
The rose.